(audience applauds)
- You look beautiful.
- Thank you very much.
- Oh my god, I love the hair right now,
oh my god.
- Thank you so much.
- Yes, and that's soft.
I don't know what the hell it's made of,
but it's soft.
- Magic.
- I'll trade. (laughs)
- Serious, we--
- We'll trade backstage, yeah
- We'll trade backstage.
- Yeah, I like that.
- I just want a day
where I can trade outfits
with either one of you. (laughs)
- I'm so excited to be
on a couch with you two.
- Well, thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you so much.
I'm such a big fan, (laughs) yes.
- I know, I can't express to you
how much I am going to rub it in
to my sister.
You're welcome, Lisa.
We were talking about female friendships.
Do you have a lot of female friendships?
- I do, my best friend is Nicole Byer,
who's been on the show. but--
- [Kelly] I love her!
- We have a podcast called "Best Friends,"
and, thank you,
and yeah, we talk about--
- From this picture alone.
(Kelly and Sasheer laugh)
- Clearly we're friends.
We love each other.
- How did y'all meet?
- We met through improv.
We were doing improv at the
Upright Citizens Brigade theater
in New York,
and we were placed on a
mashup group with our teacher.
This woman put together different
women on a team together.
And we kind of saw each
other and were like,
"She's cool," and--
- Aw, I love that.
- And then we started asking
each other to perform,
and it felt like a first
date where we were like,
"Can we do this again?"
And we've just been performing together
and writing together and working
together for like 13 years.
And I hope we have a--
- Well, finding a partner--
- Long friendship and
business relationship
as long as we can.
- And it's a rare relationship
where she's the first person that I met
where I could see her all day.
We would go to commercial
auditions together.
We would go to improv classes together.
We would go see a show
together, rehearse together,
and then split up and
then call each other,
Talk about the day that
we just had. (laughs)
- [Kelly] I love that!
- We were really obsessed with each other
- You know, what's so beautiful, though?
It's awesome to have female relationships,
but it's also, I think,
powerful to have relationships
with females in this industry,
because it's a very different thing.
Like, I have friends
that don't do what I do,
and some conversations are interesting
cuz I'll never know their perspective
on their life and they'll
never know mine, you know?
So that's even cooler
that you have a female to
lean on in this industry,
cuz this industry can be hard on females.
(audience applauds)
- So on your podcast,
with Nicole, you said hot
dogs are your love language.
Is that true?
Do you like hot dogs that much?
- I love hot dogs.
I'm a little embarrassed to talk about it
but I love them,
cuz I feel like I've talked to people
who are like, "Oh, what's the
best meal you've ever had?"
And they're like, "This pasta in Italy,"
or like, "The seafood by the bay,"
and I'm like, "I had a great
hot dog at Magic Kingdom."
(Kelly laughs)
Really do, actually, it's a funny story.
Nicole was dating a guy who worked
at a hot dog shop near
my house in New York.
- Jackpot for you.
- I mean, he like left
the job years later,
but and then they met,
you know, happenstance,
and he was like, "Weird question,
"does your best friend
Sasheer like hot dogs?"
And she was like, "Yeah, she loves them."
And he was like, "Yeah, she
would often come alone."
And I was like, "He
didn't have to say alone!"
(audience laughs)
That's, he didn't have to--
- Why'd you have to--
- Drive it in like that.
- Just say I went there a bunch.
Don't I tell other people
I was there alone often.
- And like, what's wrong with that?
- Exactly.
- There's nothing wrong with that.
I wanted a hot dog.
I went and got a hot dog.
I go places by myself.
That's what happens when you're single.
- I'm an independent woman.
If I wanna hot dog, I'm
going to get a hot dog.
(audience applauds)
- It also happens
when you're a single woman with children
and you're like, "Someone watch them,
"I need a minute."
- [Sasheer] Exactly.
- Yeah, I don't want to
surround myself with people.
There are people at home.
- Yeah, this is a private me time.
Me and my hot dog.
- Yes, I love me time.
- I have husband whose idea of a great,
it was the middle one,
(Kelly laughs)
his idea of a great vacation was traveling
around the country to all
the baseball stadiums,
so I decided my role was to figure out
which one had the best hot dogs.
- [Sasheer] That's a good job.
- Kansas City.
- Ooh!
- Kansas City Royals, their stadium.
Oh my god, best.
- Good to know, I'll have to go there now.
- I love that was
something that y'all did,
just go to stadiums, that's awesome.
Was it awesome? (laughs)
(Lily laughs)
(audience laughs)
Was it more one of those things,
like I remember with my ex I'd be like,
"Yeah, hunting is so cool."
And then I'd be like,
"I don't like hunting."
(audience laughs)
Was it one of those things?
- Yeah, but the other
husband did the hunting
and so I did it with him.
- [Sasheer] You've tried it all.
- Yeah, I've tried it all.
- Yeah, well, you don't
know which flavor you like,
that's what I say.
So let's talk about your show.
It's called "Woke" and it's in season two.
So for people that haven't
seen it and saw the clip,
what's it about?
- So "Woke" is about Keith Knight.
Keith Knight is a real
cartoonist from the Bay.
And he created this show to kind of talk
about his relationship with
his audience and his Blackness
and how he infuses his
ideologies into his work.
And so the first season of "Woke" was,
Lamorne Morris, the main
character, playing Keith Knight
and kind of him waking up
and starting to see the
injustices around him,
and like, how does he want to
talk about this in his work?
And my character is kind of already woke
and is kind of guiding
him on this journey.
And the second season, I feel like,
is really analyzing that word
and really taking apart the idea
of what is woke and what isn't
and kind of showing
that there is no right
or wrong way to do it.
Everyone's just trying their best.
And you can figure it out on your own.
But I like that it makes people think
about that kind of stuff
while also being very funny.
- Absolutely, I love thought provoking.